losing his powers and his cool rocking
over a counselor as he charges around
Rob Ford is the mayor who admitted
smoking crack cocaine and is now being
stripped of responsibilities and money
in front and they they stopped me from
hitting my head against the wall with
Toronto's council voting to transfer 60%
of the mayor's budget to his deputy many
would have quit by now but despite the
political challenges and public
humiliation Rob Ford keeps on fighting
his corner mr. city manager this is a
virtually impossible to do with eight
people with the numbers I gave you and
these are the facts and you know you can
trace this any time you want how can I
run the office as mayor with the chorus
part with the numbers I just gave you
what you know are accurate with eight
people in my office
despite his admissions of drug taking
and a string of public apologies some
still support than that he's even been
given his own TV show I'll do a drug
test an alcohol test right now why and I
put a motion forward that every
councillor do it - you know what they
jumped up they don't want anything to do
with it and then our last council
meeting says oh we're going out drinking
out there please can you get off by
saying he now wants to run for prime
minister he may have lost many powers
but Rob Ford is still the mayor as well
as the star of his own political soap
opera Clare Fallon Sky News